next Jared how can you prove your ideas
have worth it worth to even if you don't
have a social fall in a very small one
my dears and solutions have a lot to
offer big brands but proving I'm a value
is tough any suggestions yeah it sounds
like the questioner is is thinking about
maybe pitching the idea to a big brand
to market it if that's the Strand I
think you've got to stand out so you
know if your drinks company and you've
got a big idea you want to go along to
coca-cola to pitch an idea it's probably
good to start the business get the idea
get some success of momentum but then
how do you kind of stand out from the
crowd one of the things is a different
idea that jumps out to his success but
again actually the company i mentioned
before innocent they got acquired i
think a majority stay by coca-cola for
over almost hundred million dollars and
that was an idea around smoothies they
spent a lot of time months and months
blend in different smoothies all organic
really appealing to help the health
market that was evolved in there about
five years ago but they stood out so I
think with your idea if you're doing a
pitch to some of these big companies and
you want to have their market your idea
where you want to sell your company to
them then you've got to stand out but
what I would argue is you're much better
off putting your energy into your idea
of building a business rather than
worrying about selling your business
never worry about selling your business
run your business grow your business and
you'll get a lot of people knocking on
your door to say I want you to be bigger
part of a bigger family getting a lot of
uh I agree yes in the comments now do
you like it um you know for me this
comes back to the last point of the idea
is not enough I have tons of ideas for
big companies right I could walk into
McDonald's and come up with a hundred
ideas for them from how they treat
people to what's on their menu to the
kindness of the place to their website
you know the idea is good but it's not
enough you know is the are you can you
provide execution to these big brains
right McDonald's is likely not going to
pay you for an idea or whatever big
brand that you want to try to connect
with it's the idea plus the execution if
all you give
the idea then they have to execute on it
they have a list of ideas to write you
know how you have a list of ten thousand
ideas every big company has a list of
ten thousand ideas to Steven already
mentioned today about he wants to get
more done right he's got a list of ten
thousand ideas that he wants to move
sage in the right direction and so the
idea is not enough the only the only
caveat in terms of in terms of that in
my mind at least is if you have a patent
if you can patent the idea and you can
get it protected then all you're going
to go is sell the patent to the company
but then it has to be something to
stevens point before are really unique
really different something that people
will recognize but otherwise if you
can't get it patented then just selling
an idea to a company is not going to be
enough you need to have the execution
yeah on that as well I think it's fair
to say it's all about execution and
never ever kind of just stand still you
gotta win obey all the time and also
just sometimes you get lucky or
something happens in the marketplace
that kind of shifts the dollar makes
your idea relevant example company great
company but Sir customer of ours called
glowy in France back in kind of 2013
they were watching kind of marine
biology and stuff and there's this
really cool light given off farm by
creatures under seat just like Oh Krista
real idea in the era of something called
bioluminescence I can't even pronounce
it but basically it's a kind of life has
given our fantasy and then the French
legislators brought in some laws to stop
shop Sampat izing with big neo signs and
stuff like that because it was bad for
light pollution and these guys are Chloe
developed this kind of marine luminaux
technology that's environmentally very
sensitive and compliant with the law and
they built a business where they're
lighting up kind of advertising for
companies after dark in front so in
legislation change of regulations and
and also change in terms of market
requirements just be aware and always
sensitive so not only is the idea got to
evolve you got a market test it but you
and I know and this is so true now in
2016 the market is so different today
than it was five years ago and you know
Evan maybe you give some example in
terms of the gaming industry
in and everything people like oculus you
know how to add a bath you know virtual
reality is changing so quickly that
you've got to be really attuned to the
opportunities